[Music]
good morning it is November 22nd 2018
which means it is my brother's birthday
but yeah my brother's birthday happy
birthday Harry and also it is
Thanksgiving it's Thanksgiving
yeah I'm thankful for you for you too
like I snuck that in there with them
because they're watching but you know I
really meant you too sure you did you're
so cold half awake I want to sleep
really late last night for no reason why
I don't know when I fell asleep but I'm
pretty sure I fell asleep before you did
I know I really had no reason to stay up
late last night I was just on my phone
and I'm that like I'm never on my phone
I don't really like really I think like
your hug that your phone because your
job is your job like I used to be on my
phone all the time like I'm like oh I
can't live without my phone but then in
recent years now like I don't like being
on social media if I'm not posting
anything myself cuz it is like part of
the job I kind of feel for you yeah I
kind of feel weird if I'm on it
any things I feel guilty so I try to
stay away from something we do but then
Leslie I don't know I guess I missed it
and so I just stayed up really late just
looking at Instagram and Twitter and
Facebook and all that stuff that's cool
you're a cool mom you're a young
youthful adult does I feel like an old
person compared to you busy I'm never on
my phone I could rarely ever am I on my
phone I spend very little time on
Instagram you know when I post I don't
really forget about it and like I don't
know I don't find entertainment and
watching looking at memes either a very
traditional movie but yeah like I'll
show you means you're like I don't get
it and then I have to explain to me and
I'm like oh that's not fun anymore let's
have breakfast breakfast my English tea
some oatmeal made with almond milk for
mine cuz I'm trying not to do the whole
Gary thing and I got some almonds for
some healthy fats and protein walnuts
for omega-3 fatty acids blueberries and
blackberries or whatever they do
antioxidants I think and then a touch of
cinnamon or anti-inflammatory properties
that cinnamon provides yeah it was just
all in the end when you're not the other
all right so we are now going to start
cooking the most festive part about
Thanksgiving is not eating it's the
cooking I'm about to enjoy myself right
now for this Thanksgiving we are not
doing turkey because well quite frankly
we just don't like turkey like it's
gonna be a pretty small but not too
small but not too big kind of dinner
like a medium like a medium-size like a
Goldilocks friendly side right yeah the
people that are coming they're like we
don't care about Turkey so Brandon
suggested he's like oh but you know what
I do love Casey smoked duck so that's
what Casey's gonna be making smoke get
some duck I have it all pretty seasoned
I have three ducks so since there's so
many people coming over and you by
turkeys it's like 14 pound turkey that's
a smaller you fourteen pounds so I
bought three ducks which equals fifteen
pounds total of each one is about five
pounds figured that'd be a nice
compromise for the amount of food that
ducks a good yield this is also a
potluck style Thanksgiving so we'll have
more food that people will be bringing
this is not like the only thing
everyone's eating and I'm gonna go get
mashed potatoes here I'll help you film
your okay okay I'm not gonna cook these
yet I'm gonna make gravy out of like oh
yeah out of the giblets so you know you
buy poultry it comes with all this guts
right here they're not guys your giblets
saved it and I'm going to giblets then
if it's not good how come they don't
call it guts then if it is good they
like guts it's like the slang term I
think Gus is like the intestines right
yeah what are giblets I have no idea
with liver and I see liver here part in
there yeah there's a heart right here
it's hard that's the heart whoa crazy
something that's the part that's the
giblet I don't know see what is a giblet
I don't know and there's this thing this
one looks different this is the heart
maybe I don't know and then just a lot
of excess skin for that the fat is
flavor but yeah so first things first
when the gravy is tomato broth a duck
broth so I make my own custom props
right now
[Music]
all right well he's cookin I'm gonna go
get ready
I kind of wanted to show you guys how
I'm gonna do my hair so I kind of did
this thing right I'm not in love with so
instead I'm gonna curl my hair I'll just
have you guys off to the side while I
curl my hair oh wait I'll show you this
I updated my vanity with these little
lights ha then that cool I bought them
on Amazon to like you just stick them to
your your mirror and then oh my god just
by going up the stairs oh my goodness is
home out of shape oh and I also got this
jewelry box thingy cuz I got tired of
all my stuff hanging here I don't know
if you guys ever noticed in the other
videos and I just kind of like cleaned
things up a bit in my vanity this thing
also for my azan I'm gonna set you guys
down and I'm gonna curl my hair in case
you guys are wondering what I'm using to
curl my hair it's this one by ultra yeah
I got this wand at beautycon and that
actually rhymes
I got it from one of those like goody
bags that they give and it's just like a
whole bunch of free stuff cuz I love
free stuff but this is actually a really
good one
alright now my hair's all cruel but I
like to do just run my fingers through
it you know what I wish I got a slightly
bigger barrel cuz this barrel is too
small which makes me have like my hair
really high up and like really tight
curls so I've been trying to curl my
hair recently to get more practice cuz I
have so many tools like hair tools to
curl my hair like I could make an entire
video on how many tools I have to curl
my hair but I never use them because
it's either too hard to use or I'm too
lazy or I just don't have the confidence
in using them because I need to practice
more so now just kind of been forcing
myself to practice curling my hair so
it's just like I'm gonna get it right
one of these days this is pretty crazy
hopefully it goes down
get out yeah this is like really curly I
was trying to do a beach wave kind of
thing where I leave the ends kind of
straight but like I said I'm not a pro
yeah this is pretty wild
I feel like it it kind of feels like
really vivacious you know I don't know
is that a word I think that's a word you
have to pin up the side hopefully that
makes it less [ __ ] me it's good this is
my look for today I just gotta do my
makeup get dressed and I'm ready for a
feast I'm gonna teach you guys how to
start a smoker I've already laid out the
charcoal and the wood the next step to
start a smoker is any one of these
chimneys or here charcoal goes on the
top side of it and you see there's a
catch right there on the bottom side
this is where you start your filthy down
there this is where you put your your
paper there's a turf of this you stick
your fire-starting stuff in there to
heat up the charcoal that's in here and
once the truffles heated up you pours
over the carpet is really laid out
already that should do it
charcoal goes in the top side
[Music]
we're gonna take a break from that smoke
we're gonna let the chimney do its job
for about 20 minutes so that it can burn
off all that paper and here at the
charcoal super excited about this recipe
one of my favorite things to smoke on
the smoker is a duck so when I do my
smoked duck I like to put in that flavor
of the Chinese barbecue roasted Peking
duck so inside the cavity here put in
some secret ancient Chinese spices and
on the outside just basic salt pepper
garlic and some onion powder an easy way
to know when your coals are ready and
they're hot
is when the smoke stops looking at this
nice little flame going on that means
that the charcoal is empery
[Music]
water pan here they keep the Ducks moist
and then the grade slips go right on top
[Music]
all right so I'm all done with my hair
I'm all done with my makeup I got
dressed ignore my slippers but this is
my outfit for today I'm very
Thanksgiving we got my hair like this to
get it out of my face and I was doing my
makeup and I ended up liking how it
looks I'm just gonna leave like this
people are gonna start writing pretty
soon I'm gonna get started on making the
mashed potatoes Casey's been smoking
this duck I'm just excited to eat so our
first guests have arrived
cannon Bri my gosh it's tiny just
kidding it looks like a normal oh wait
that's a boardgame yeah my mind
registered a card game some lightweight
that looks normal but then I was like
wait wait he said board games
so how cute didn't really like that one
so really like push your luck and you
know why oh yeah oh you gamble he loves
Ambo dia alright so I just got back from
the store I had to go out and buy more
potatoes because we did we didn't
realize that we didn't have enough
potatoes so I'm going to put this apron
on and get to cooking cuz you should go
and most of the cooking so far desserts
yeah I'm gonna make some fresh baked
well it's not fresh baked quick
at least it'll be hot and out of the
oven fresh iodine I'm like oh you should
you should just drop them lightly like
right write a book oh yeah there we go
yeah you're smart utensils Joe is so
smart
that's what I made the same mistakes as
you did
when I make salute I just do that
solitude here alright let's go check up
on the schmuck duck
[Music]
all right so all of the potato masters
were sold out but luckily we have a
whisk all we need a sausage on this one
hey sausage on this and I'm done I
grabbed it
I'm grabbing it that's my face it's
distracting okay deliver the head now
this is serious huh this is hell yeah
we've been playing for like an hour yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]